- I'm 20 years old and I'm
addicted to drinking gasoline.
- Eating bugs.
- Rescuing food from dumpsters.
- Eating sand.
- People have some strange addictions
and they actually made a show about it,
and while you may be tempted to laugh,
hear me out in my points
first before going to judge.
Bewoop.
- My name is Nathaniel, I'm 27 years old
and I'm in a serious
relationship with my car.
- Interesting.
- [Nathaniel] Morning, baby.
- It's a pretty car, I'm not gonna lie,
I'm digging the color.
- It's like it was love at first sight.
His body, and then his interior,
and everything just
together just seemed to fit
and I just felt an instant connection.
(suspenseful music)
- You know, this objectophilia
seems like it runs
in a similar pattern as animism,
where someone believes that
a inanimate object has a
spirit that is living on
and that's why they fall in love with it.
- [Narrator] Nathaniel's
relationship with Chase
goes beyond dates and presents.
- We have our times when we get sexual.
Does that feel good?
- There has been some
research that has showed
a sexual gratification or objectification
of inanimate objects does sometimes run
in a similar course also with autism,
so I don't know if autism
was in fact diagnosed
in this case.
- I'm 19 years old
and I'm addicted to eating sand.
- Sand, okay.
- [Brea] I just love the crutch.
- That's not good for the teeth.
There's a condition known as Pica
where individuals actually
crave foods like sand,
soil, paint, even metal objects,
and there are treatments for it.
- [Narrator] Brea is so dependent
on that satisfying crunch,
she turns to nail files when
her sand supply runs low.
- It has like sandpaper on it
that gives me the same crunch,
so I put it like in the back of my teeth
and just go like this.
- Essentially, you're
sanding down your teeth.
When you grind them down with
that very abrasive surface
of the sandpaper, you're
actually doing serious damage
to it.
I wouldn't be surprised if
she's going to need dentures
or implants very early on in her life,
unless this gets addressed.
- I'm 20 years old and I'm
addicted to drinking gasoline.
- Gasoline is toxic,
and I'm not just saying
drinking it, inhaling it,
getting it on your skin.
In fact, individuals who work
surrounding gasoline vapor
have higher rates of certain illnesses.
Animal studies have showed
kidney, liver disease
from extended exposure to gasoline vapors.
- I can't go a day without it.
Like, I crave it.
I need it.
I'll wake up, go to the
washroom and drink the gas.
- This is super dangerous
because of a compound called
hydrocarbons found within gasoline,
which actually act as essential
nervous system depressant.
You can almost feel like
you're drunk off of it,
but the danger that it
causes to your GI tract,
your vital organs, outweigh
any potential benefit
of consuming it.
- [Narrator] Stanley
might be 31 years old,
but for the past 18 years,
he has gone to remarkable
lengths to remain young at heart.
Very young.
- Okay, I understand
if you're watching at home
and you're quick to judge
this gentleman and say, wow,
this is clearly a disorder.
Wait.
The way we decide in
medicine and healthcare
whether or not something is a disorder
is based on the patient's own life.
If the patient is not having an issue
maintaining a job, maintaining
healthy social connections,
maintaining a relationship,
if all these major developmental
aspects of life are normal,
this is not a disorder.
We have to be very careful
with our definitions here.
- [Narrator] And he doesn't
just talk the baby talk,
he dedicates eight hours a
day role-playing as a toddler.
- That's an important fact to hear,
because if you have to
dedicate eight hours of the day
to do this, can you maintain a job?
Can you maintain social connections?
- It's a feeling of being safe,
something I didn't have
when I was growing up.
And being an adult baby
became my way of coping
with the world and my own problems.
- Humans are great at finding
unique coping mechanisms,
this works for him, something
else may work for you.
Just, we have to make
the decision together
with a patient and a doctor,
whether or not that coping mechanism is
(A) appropriate for who you are
and (B) whether or not it
is distracting or detracting
from your everyday life.
- [Narrator] Stanley has
even tried baby formula,
but like every other toddler,
he can be extremely selective.
- I mean, baby food like that
is basically just like mashed up fruit,
so it's not like the end
of the world eating that.
But like baby formula,
breast milk, all that,
really high fat content,
you really have to be careful.
- I don't have any broken bones,
but I'm addicted to putting
orthopedic casts on my body.
- What?
- I'm perfectly fine, perfectly healthy,
I like the feeling of the cast around me.
- Just wear a compression sleeve.
- I've done like two full arm
casts, two full leg casts,
I've done two full leg
cast and an arm cast.
I've put on so many different
casts, it's ridiculous.
- He just wants to be cuddled, I get it.
I need that too, sometimes.
I just don't go all the
way to getting a cast done,
but like, sometimes I
do that with a blanket
and then I lay on top of it so
I feel like I can't get out.
It's like being swaddled.
- I was 12 years old, I
broke my arm rollerblading
and I got my first cast.
I got a lot of attention with the cast on
and it's just kinda been an
ongoing process ever since then.
- That is a medical diagnosis, actually.
People who feign illness
in order to get attention
or sympathy, that needs
to be obviously diagnosed
- My name is Dave Gracer and
I'm obsessed with eating bugs.
- Initial impression of mine
is this might not be so bad,
because bugs are actually
kind of nutritious.
- [Narrator] He's eaten
more than 5,000 bugs
over the past 11 years.
- Does he keep track
of the numbers of bugs?
That's interesting.
- When it comes to getting
bugs, you got to kill them,
and there's a variety
of ways of doing that.
I prefer freezing them
because you go to sleep,
so I think it's the most humane way.
- You don't just go to
sleep, you're viciously cold
and then you go to sleep.
It's not like he's giving
them a paralytic agent
to knock them out and then freezing them.
- David's interest in eating insects
just kept getting bigger.
- Grasshopper, grasshopper, grasshopper.
- And bigger.
- [David] Fly, pupa, cicada.
- Scorpion tastes kind of
like this weird plastic.
- And you enjoy eating weird plastic?
Like, I want to know his explanation.
I have follow-up questions.
- I started going into the
woods and getting my own bugs,
and I think the first ones
I found was a whole log full
of carpenter ants, and I tried those.
- Ants are very rich in protein.
Ants, grasshoppers.
Like, grasshoppers almost have
the same amount of protein
per hundred grams as red meat does.
- [Narrator] When he wants
something more exotic,
he goes to his personal
supermarket, the pet store.
Today, he is picking up
a specially ordered bug
he has never encountered.
- [David] That gnat is a
monster. I will eat a monster.
- You want to make sure
that you're thinking about
toxins that the bug has inside of them.
The bacteria that's on the bugs.
You also want to think
about anti-nutrients
that are actually meant
to discourage predators
from eating them by not
allowing us to withdraw
the protein from the foods,
and it actually stops
the protein absorption inside our bodies.
- [Narrator] The Vietnamese Centipede
is the only species of centipede
to have ever killed a human being.
- Wow.
- Right in the oil.
I'll season them again just real quick,
we'll do salt and pepper.
- How does he know to season
it with salt and pepper?
How does he know those flavors go together
if he's never eaten it before?
That's just like throwing salt
on an already potentially
salty food and be like, hmm.
- [Narrator] The heat not
only cooks the insect,
it also breaks down the poisonous venom.
- There you go, take a peak
and see what we've done today
for you, Dave.
- [Dave] Oh, my God.
It's still got the very
much the look of the beast.
- The look of the beast.
- But there's so much muscle tissue.
- I feel like I was about to throw up.
- I understand why you say that.
This concept isn't that out there for me
because by eating more insects,
we can place less strain on our land,
have highly, highly nutritious
and protein rich foods
brought to our diet,
especially in areas where we
don't have farming abilities.
I've actually tasted grasshopper before.
Not too shabby.
- We're the strongest-
- Family-
- In the world.
- Whoa.
- [Narrator] Nick, Kelly,
Dylan
and Jessica Best,
train their bodies up
to 240 hours each week.
- That's a lot of hours of training.
- [Narrator] While some
pediatricians warn against
weight training for
kids, 11 year old Dylan
routinely deadlifts 130 pounds.
- I do like working out.
Just like my coffee in the morning,
if I don't do it, I don't feel right.
- I love that this kid is so mature.
Initially looking at this,
11 years old is probably
on the earlier side
of starting to lift heavy weights.
The idea is that you risk injury
when you have non-fully formed
muscles, tendons, ligaments,
bones, and start lifting heavy weights.
It can be done safely, you
just need to be very careful
and monitored by a professional.
Kids below the age of seven
shouldn't be doing weightlifting at all.
Starting at age seven,
you could start incorporating
strength training,
that's good, but just
not with heavy weights.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, JJ.
- [Narrator] Experts
recommend children her age
train with one pound weights.
- [Kelly] Whoa!
- [Narrator] But she can lift 100 pounds.
- That's probably not ideal.
That being said, I doubt
that this is going to do
any real damage to her growth plates,
that was kind of a myth
that we had published
by the American Academy
of Pediatrics in 1983
where we thought that could happen,
it was a potential risk.
And then as time went on, we
saw that happen less and less,
especially with proper training.
- [Narrator] Dylan and Jessica consume
nearly twice the recommended
calories for their age.
- While we do give
recommendations on caloric intake,
that is a wide ranging recommendation
that needs to be individualized.
So for children that are
highly active like them,
and we see how their weight
and their BMI is trending,
we can make different
changes to their diets
and to their recommendations.
So the fact that they're eating a lot more
than an average child
isn't that wild to me
because they're burning a lot of calories
by doing all of these
workouts several times a day.
- Hi, I'm Kelly Athena
and I'm obsessed with
rescuing food from dumpsters.
- I'm with it.
We waste so much food in this country
while other countries starve,
I don't think this is a terrible idea,
I just hope they're doing it safely.
- [Narrator] The average
American household
spends over $500 a month on groceries.
- And we oftentimes
spend money on groceries
that look the prettiest and waste the food
that may not look pretty
but is just as nutritious,
just as tasty.
- Everything I have in my
fridge, I got from the dumpster.
Apples, cucumbers,
pickles, condiments,
grapes, cantaloupe.
Here's some soy milk I had,
and it even expired more than a month ago.
- Sometimes it's a full
on expiration date,
but you really need to
understand what that date is for
'cause that date could be
like for ideal freshness
or for ideal taste, it still might be
calorically, nutritionally, valuable.
- [Kelly] I'm not afraid to
eat right out of the dumpster
if it's good stuff.
There's this peach,
if I peel it, that'll
be pretty safe to eat.
If I eat out at a restaurant,
I don't know who's preparing
that food bag there.
- I don't know if I'm a fan of that logic.
You don't know who's preparing the food?
At least it's cooked.
Here, you're getting food that's
been living in a dumpster.
What if a raccoon pooped on it?
- [Narrator] She is spicing up
the four month old
dumpster pizza with cheese
two weeks past its expiration date,
overripe tomatoes Kelly found a week ago.
- [Husband] Maybe a little diced fennel.
- [Narrator] Fennel found
at the bottom of a trash bin
just this morning.
- Well, it's a fresh dumpster fennel.
- [Narrator] And frozen chicken.
- Chicken, if it was even
not frozen for a short period
of time, bacteria can
start proliferating on it,
especially if it wasn't
stored or prepared properly.
Oh, man.
I've had a personal close friend of mine
who eats thoroughly cooked
foods, eat out at a restaurant,
get an infection from one of those foods
and then develop an abscess,
which is a pocket of infection
inside his brain, and he
still has neurologic effects
as a result of that,
so this isn't like totally benign.
I also reviewed Family by the Ton,
living life as an 800 pound person.
Click here to check that out.
As always, stay happy and healthy.